America you're having sex but you're not
having babies
so Trojan is here to help introducing
the Trojan turtlenecks
it's a Trojan quality you trust without
that baby preventing reservoir growth
simply unroll the turtleneck and let the
safe fish sex began so why would I even
need to use a condom because the Trojan
turtleneck keeps you safe from all
sexually transmitted Shaq borne diseases
including Rodrick Pole no cylinder o
erection inflammation shaft shingles
Sherman's drew and boner eczema also
available in ribbed for her pleasure oh
wait what are you doing with the tips of
all those condoms don't worry about it
trojan turtleneck condoms the world's
first reproduce electic
I'll put it very interesting that people
were enjoying that and then they started
the list
totally fake diseases and everyone was
watching like huh
Sherman's drew well maybe that is boner
excellent Andy I hope when they make the
ad for boner eczema you're the guy doing
it I could use the cash frankly